die große frage an diesem tag ist was
ist los in diesem land duisburg am
hellichten abend mitten in der stadt auf
offener straße 80 bis 100 männer rotten
sich zusammen gehen wird mit
schlagstöcken aufeinander los dann
fallen schüsse unfassbare szenen gestern
abend szenen die inzwischen fast zum
alltag gehören in deutschland immer
wieder im fokus der ermittler clans und
rocker
duisburg nordrhein westfalen ein lauer
frühlingstag
ob
hells angels gegen libanesischen
großfamilie während die duisburger die
belebten straßen in den feierabend
passieren treffen sich fast 100
bewaffnete männer am hamborner altmarkt
rocker auf offener straße
altmarkt mehrere personen
zusammengerottet haben und es dort zu
massiven auseinandersetzungen kommt die
schließlich auch in einen schusswechsel
geändert sind wir konnten bisher 19
hülsen 9 mm am tatort finden also sind
mindestens 19 schuss abgegeben worden
das motiv nach bild-informationen wirft
rocker boss seelow ein libanesisches
mitglied aus seinem klub weil es seine
rocker brüder bei der polizei verpfeift
verstoß gegen den rocker kodex
unschuldige passanten bringen sich
gerade rechtzeitig in sicherheit
doch die brutale auseinandersetzung in
duisburg ist kein einzelfall in der
bundesrepublik immer wieder kommt es zu
brutalen schießereien auf offener straße
ohne rücksicht auf unbeteiligte
immer wieder im mittelpunkt dieser
straftaten clans und drucker
[Applaus]
dortmunds november
2021 die blutige eskalation einer
monatelang andauernden familienfehde
wegen der döner preise mit einem döner
messer pistolen und geschirr gehen die
familien aufeinander los spuren ins
klaren oder rocker milieu schließt die
polizei explizit nicht aus mehrere
männer kommen mit schnitt und
schussverletzungen ins krankenhaus
wenige wochen vorher und weniger als 100
kilometer weiter in köln eskaliert der
rockerkrieg zwischen hells angels ammann
b und seinem chef hat erika nachdem der
mucki rocker ein umstrittenes instagram
video veröffentlicht erklärt sein chef
ihn für vogelfrei wenig später der
versuchte mordanschlag auf sah man wie
vor seiner haustür in köln ehrenfeld
doch auch in der hauptstadt stehen
gefährliche schießereien auf der
tagesordnung juni vergangenen jahres
zwei maskierte männer schießen in einer
lauen sommernacht gezielt auf gäste
einer shisha bar nach bild-informationen
peitschen insgesamt 28 schüsse durch die
berliner nacht die spur geht ins clan
milieu
nur beispiele der hemmungslosen und
brutalen auseinandersetzungen der clans
und rocker aus getragen auf deutschen
straßen das problem ist noch lange nicht
gelöst wir haben ein problem von
kriminalität im organisierten bereich
bei clans und barocker und wir brauchen
noch viel aufwand um das sie griff zu
kriegen zurück nach duisburg noch in der
nacht stürmte das sek das haus einer
libanesischen großfamilie
insgesamt nimmt die polizei 15 männer
fest und ermittelt unter hochdruck um
die brutalen schützen des duisburger
rockerkrieges zu fassen die fahndung
läuft
bild chefreporter frank schneider r
kennt sich aus wie kaum ein zweiter in
der clan und rockerszene frank wie kann
es zu einer derartigen gewaltorgie komme
auf offener straße mitten in der stadt
ja das ist schon eine neue qualität auch
für die polizei und alle sind eigentlich
erschrocken darüber dass das so
eskalieren konnte in der szene selbst
ist man auch ein wenig erschrocken aber
dort ist sie also die situation weiter
so angespannt weil natürlich jetzt
mindestens vier personen angeschossen
wurden nach unseren informationen
möglicherweise zwei weitere die sich
aber wenn ich in behandlung im
krankenhaus begeben haben weil sie ja
dann logischerweise auch in den fokus
der polizei gerutscht werden und diese
eskalation ist einfach damit zu
begründen dass echt die rocker ehre die
familienehre diese ganzen falschen
ehrvorstellungen die diese herren haben
vermischt worden sind dann ging es um
den rausschmiss aus dem klub das geht
nicht das kann man sich vor der familie
nicht bieten lassen der beleidigt
wiederum den rocker boss der rocker boss
will sich das nicht bieten lassen ja und
dann soll es angeblich zur aussprache
kommen wo die aussprache ist von beiden
seiten mehr oder weniger die weitere
eskalation und man bringt scharfe
schusswaffen mit und man setzt sie eben
auch rücksichtslos ein und das ist ja
nun wirklich reines wunder dass nicht
unbeteiligte verletzt worden sind denn
da ist ja wird nicht wild rum geschossen
worden wie man das in deutschland zum
glück ja so häufig bisher nicht erlebt
hat trotzdem hat man das gefühl dass ich
da parallelgesellschaften gründen und
der staat mehr oder weniger machtlos
zuschauen
ja das problem ist also eigentlich
gerade hier nordrhein westfalen hat man
ja durch das kunden verbot das ist ja
mehr oder weniger auch bundesweit hat
man die hackerszene schon ein wenig
sozusagen von dem straßenbild
verschwinden lassen die clans zähnen
hier nordrhein westfalen hat steht ja
auch unter immensem druck weil
innenminister rollen immer wieder
kontrollen durchführt immer wieder
razzien durchführte erst gestern morgen
war ja eine klare linien als seinen
klaren da geht es wieder um geldwäsche
und eigentlich hatte man das gefühl
durch diese permanenten nadelstich diese
permanenten razzien diesen permanent
kontrolldruck hat man die szene ein
wenig im griff aber sobald es darum das
ehrgefühl geht um verletzte ehre
gekränkten stolz auch um geld dann
sollte jemand einfach das sind ja alles
begriffe in dieser in dieser szene und
dann eskaliert plötzlich so etwas
dermaßen und keine seite steckt zurück
und deshalb ist natürlich auch die ganz
große sorge der polizei dass das eben
noch weitergeht man will angeblich in
der szene möglicherweise auch wieder mit
friedensrichter mit anderen personen
versuchen die situation ja ich sage mal
vorsichtig zu glätten aber ob das
funktioniert ist sehr schwer
vorzustellen
und wenn die polizei franken duisburg
mit einem offenen straßen krieg zu tun
hat muss heute in hamburg eine
beerdigung eines clan mitglied
überwachen das ganze an bevor wir weiter
sprechen
rund 1000 trauergäste und 170 polizisten
das ist das aufgebot zur beerdigung von
mohamed m die klaren beerdigung findet
auf dem zwölf apostel friedhof in berlin
schöneberg statt unter den trauergästen
auch klar grösser arafat abou chaker
sowie sein bruder nasa auch andere klare
köpfe wie isar i mo und mammut algerien
sollen da gewesen sein die stimmung
die überwiegend männer also die frauen
trauern in der regel später nach den
männern sind ruhig haben sich auf dem
gegenüberliegenden bürgersteig bewegt
und sind da relativ zügig nach dem
leichenwagen auf das friedhofsgelände
geströmt mohamed m wurde am samstagabend
auf einem neuköllner straßenfest
erstochen rettungskräfte versuchten
vergeblich das leben des 25 jährigen zu
retten
mohammed teilt damit das schicksal
seines bruders nidal der 2018 erschaffen
wurde der ältere bruder nidal r der elf
jahre alter ist vor drei jahren auf dem
flughafen berlin tempelhof auf dem
ehemaligen flughafengelände am
hellichten tage erschossen worden da
ging es um ehre da ging es um
streitereien mit einem anderen klang und
der kleine bruder momo genannt mohammed
erfüllte sich seitdem extrem bedroht und
soll tag und nacht mit einer schusswaffe
eben auch sich selber geschützt haben
wie soll er auch bei dem rummel fest in
der hasenheide dabei gehabt haben am
samstag er soll sie sogar gezogen haben
und augenzeugen berichten dass er
abgedrückt hat den abzug gezogen hat
aber sich eben kein schuss gelöst hat
entweder hatte die wahl für ladehemmung
oder war vielleicht noch gesichert das
weiß man noch nicht und diesen moment
soll der täter dann ausgenutzt haben um
eben die tödlichen stiche beizubringen
der mörder von mohammed ist noch nicht
gefasst offenbar müssen sich polizei und
justiz darauf einstellen dass die
großfamilie auf eigene faust nach ihm
suchen wird
also nochmals zu frank schneider 170
polizisten müssen eine beerdigung
bewachen alles steuergelder die da ja
sozusagen genutzt werden riesige klaren
beerdigung ist davon auszugehen dass die
großfamilie selbst nach dem täter suchen
wird und auch selbstjustiz üben wird
ja das steht zu befürchten gerade in dem
konkreten fall ist es ja eben so wir
haben ja gerade im beitrag gehört das
schon der zweite bruder getötet wurde
und ein dritter bruder wurde auch
bereits schon angeschossen nach
erkenntnissen der polizei ist es so dass
diese familie mehr oder weniger auch
häufig in dem milieu die drecksarbeit
macht für die clans und von anderen
clans eingesetzt wird werden gerade auch
gehört es waren mehrere klaren größen
verschiedener familien da und diese
familie wurde sozusagen benutzt um
geschäfte zu machen hat er sich eben die
finger schmutzig zu machen und am ende
geht es eben immer genau wie das gehört
habe um ehre und um geld das sind die
beiden faktoren die entscheidend sind
und wenn irgendetwas nicht nachsagen mal
der der vorstellung einer familie oder
eines eines paten läuft dann gibt es
sofort reibereien häufig versucht man
ohne polizei ohne eben aufsehenerregende
auseinandersetzung die dinge mit
friedensrichter oder ähnlichen zu klären
aber wenn so ein streit so lange
gespielt und jetzt schon den zweiten
toten fordert steht auch da zu
befürchten dass das blutig weitergeht
können wir uns gesehen auch im ersten
beitrag also gestern abend duisburg wir
haben gesehen dortmund wir haben gesehen
berlin
überall in deutschland in vielen städten
gibt es diese klaren strukturen wo
überall genau und wie sieht das aus
naja großfamilien in clans immer so ein
begriff diese großfamilie gerade die
libanesischen großfamilien teilweise
türkischer abstammung die gibt es
insbesondere in berlin dann ist noch ein
hotspot bremen und dann insbesondere
essen und das umliegende ruhrgebiet das
heißt gelsenkirchen duisburg diese
städte und dort hat man sich über die
ganzen jahre mehr oder weniger
eingenistet das ist lange von der
politik mehr oder weniger nicht ernst
genommen worden die polizei auch keine
rückendeckung und dann haben sich dass
strukturen entwickelt und gerade hier im
ruhrgebiet ist es zum teil mittlerweile
so dass jetzt weitere großfamilien von
anderen ländern hier in strömen das sind
zum beispiel jura das sind iraker und
wenn wir dann den blick mal ins
europäische ausland machen nämlich nach
schweden dort sind es eben keine
libanesischen plans dort gibt es ja auch
massive auseinandersetzung im milieu da
gibt es mittlerweile langwaffen angriffe
da gibt es sprengstoffanschläge
handgranaten anschläge und das sind eben
mehr syrische clans also das heißt die
gefahr dass noch andere clans auf diesen
markt drängen denn es geht um einen
ihrer großen kuchen nämlich sehr sehr
viel geld und da besteht die gefahr dass
es weiter blutige und brutale
auseinandersetzung gibt in der gefahr
dass es irgendwann auch mal unbeteiligte
trifft und der start scheint machtlos